hmm
chair we're streaming live now um so you
can start thank you
that's rather good i made a mistake then
good afternoon and welcome to the
overview and scrutiny to committee
all participants are taking part
remotely and we are live streaming to
youtube
there will now be a roll call for
confirmation that members of the
committee
are present can you please carry out the
role call trish
counselor counselor austin
hasn't joined us yet um
councillor d cox i don't think he's
joining deceiver
um councillor dawes i'm here
sorry i've just had a message david cox
he's trying to get in at the moment
okay okay um councillor evans
yes president
cancer hayes president
cancer herc here councillor morgan
present councillor nettle present
that's a parker khan yeah councillor
pedreck
president councillor tomb
[Music]
present um councillor swain
here and your self
chair present
so that's um so we're all present apart
from councillor
david cox who's um trying to join us and
councillor austin thank you so much
can cancers please make sure all
microphones are muted when you're not
speaking to avoid any background noise
levels
please keep any points short and don't
interrupt when somebody is speaking
if you wish to comment please raise your
electronic hand and wait to be called
when it comes to a vote if you are to
roll call
the democratic services officer we'll
read out members names
will members please say if they're
voting for against
or abstaining alternatively the vote
will be taken by show of hands
we will look to have a break at a
convenient time from 90 minutes into the
meeting
if required if members lose internet
connection the meeting will be paused
for a few minutes to allow
the member to rejoin so before we
move on to your agenda councillor swain
will in fact be taking the chair from
item
uh six on the agenda as we move forward
um are there any uh
declarations of interest please i'm
sorry are there any um apologies tree
um no apologies chairman other than bear
austin's not with us
and david cox is um trying to still
trying to do
still trying to join okay thank you
uh minutes of the meeting held on the
12th of january 2021.
i'll have a proposal in a second for
those minutes
to be approved as a correct record
i propose
do we have a second for those minutes
please happy to second
chair you're on sorry can i have a
show of hands to indicate your approval
of those minutes please
thank you are there anybody disagreeing
with the approval of those minutes
i can't see anybody on my screens
anymore
in that case those minutes are approved
i'll sign with you next time we get
together to be able to sign them
declarations of interest are there any
declarations of interest from
members present
i'm not seeing any declarations of
interest from anyone thank you
i there are no public questions and i
have
no notification of any counsellor
questions
so at this point if i can move the chair
please across to
council swain and thank you very much
i'll stay in the meeting as long as i
can but um over to your accounts this
way
thank you chad um so the next item
agenda is item six the executive forward
plan
which is linked on the agenda um any
questions or comments about this
and can i just check item six i've got
on my um
yes my apologies there was an incorrect
uh version of the agenda
um went out which i'm working from my
apologies the work program is item six
does anyone have any questions or
comments about this
um catch the hook
thanks it's just that um i think we have
three presentations
uh today um which is fine
and i'm sure they'll be very worthwhile
next meeting on the march the i think
it's the eighth out of my head
um we have two ph presentations
um and i think those are very important
um i think they can be very informative
and so on and so forth
would it be possible as a general
principle
um to perhaps have just one ph
presentation
a meeting i don't know if that fits in
with the you know the annual plan of
getting
everything done in the year but
i personally place quite a high
significance to those portfolio holder
reports
because it's an opportunity for members
to
question in some depth the the workings
of that those departments that they they
represent
and if we cram two in usually towards
the end of the meeting
as per this morning about their only
about i think six or seven members
left by the time we got to that
presentation and um
that is necessarily the best way of
scrutinizing the work of
of ph's or their departments um
i would be happy to pass that suggestion
on to the chair who will be in in
in in post next meeting um if you're
happy with that
yeah i just i just floated you know as a
thought
for members because um it seems a fair
suggestion to be considered as
as long as limiting it to one postholder
doesn't mean it's too long before we see
people again
chair if if i may um it is customary to
have a
executive member um
presentation at each meeting um but they
they were put um they were put back to
the ninth of march
um from one today because of the items
on the agenda today and also
there's less items on the web program
for the ninth so
um that's the only reason why there
isn't one on there today but there would
normally be at least
um one per meeting if that helps
that does help thank you very much um
are you happy with that
council luck any further questions on
the i'm sorry
thank you um i just wondered i i have
attended it was an
s1 meeting actually um and one of the
presentations went on for some 40
possibly 45 minutes
if we restricted the amount of time
perhaps to a 15-minute presentation with
time for questioning
that might keep us um more sharply
focused
and and to get the real credible points
in um but also i do recall that we had
councillor mcgregor quite a short while
ago came and presented to us on sport
and leisure
and recreation so i'm wondering if we
need him back quite so soon
or whether we'd have him further along
in the cycle
again those are fair questions which i'm
happy to pass on to the chair of the
next meeting
thank you um anything further on the
work program
so item seven then is the executive
forward plan
um any questions or comments about this
okay thank you very much so itemate on
the agenda is connecting devon and
somerset
so we welcome matt barrow from devon
county council who will update us on the
uh on this issue and answer questions um
along with neil blaney who's the head of
place and commercial services
and councilor martin wrigley and the
executive member so
i'll hand that over thank you
thank you chair and um to councillor
parker khan's comments
uh i have a feeling that i was the
guilty party with a
40-minute presentation so i i promise i
will do my best to be
uh more concise this time around but
i've got quite a lot to get through
um briefly to introduce myself my name
is matt barrow i am
the program stakeholder engagement
officer for connecting devon and
somerset
so it's my role to act as an interface
between
communities and elected members and the
work of the program
um i just want to run you through the
slides as quickly as
i possibly can uh apologies to either
those of you who
who sat through this this morning or
people who are familiar with this but i
do think it's important to provide
a bit of context for the the work of
connecting them in somerset what it is
we do and why
so we're a partnership organization of
local authorities
the local enterprise partnership and
central government through department of
culture media and sport
and we are we exist to deliver
uh speeds of super fast or higher
uh to as much of the population of
devon and somerset and the northern
unitaries
as we possibly can for for
all of the obvious reasons around
business support community support
and public sector transformation um
specifically we operate where industry
says that they won't go
and it's an important point to make and
a distinction
that essentially we cannot use taxpayer
money simply to
prop up commercial enterprise so the
process is around
uh self-declaration and we ask industry
where it is they are intending to build
over the next 18 months to three years
and armed with that information we
target those communities
and individual properties that they
identify as being not commercially
viable
so essentially if without state aid
and support from the taxpayer those
properties would not be delivered
it is an important distinction because
it means that we
target the very hardest to reach um and
in the simplest of terms we target the
rural areas of the
cds patch and industry targets the the
urban areas where economies have scaled
me that there's more commercial
viability
um we're a large-scale infrastructure
program
um increasingly where in some respects
of civil engineering rather than it
program
and operate broadly very broadly in
phases so our first phase worked with
bt and open reach to deliver across the
region
using fibre to the cabinet technology
and i'll come back to that in a moment
and then phase two builds out from the
um the delivery on that uh but
essentially moves into
a fiber to the premise methodology
rather than fiber to the cabinet
um phase one was contracted with bt
phase two
we are currently contracted with airband
wessex internet and true speed
uh across the overall region um i'm not
glossing over in any way shape or form
the fact that we
originally let five out of our six
phase two contracts to giga clear um
and many of you will be aware of the
demise of those contracts towards the
end of 2019
um and i'll pick up on that in a little
bit
overall phase one delivered from the cds
funded
element around 300 000 properties and
the the bullets here list
300 000 premises past 270 000 super fast
i have to be honest that's slightly out
of date and it is actually now 300
000 um slightly plus uh super
fast delivered the the difference
between those two figures
and and the the same remains the case
now
is that some premises are passed and
achieve
a significant improvement in speeds but
they don't quite hit that magical super
fast 30 meg per second figure so we
don't actually count them as premises
past
and indeed significantly uh those
premises remain
eligible for support um in latter phases
we then moved on to a phase where we
addressed dartmoor and xmore
um as particularly difficult uh terrains
and geographies to reach
with usually very very poor speeds and
we delivered those with our band using
fixed wireless
deployment to deliver to to over 5000
properties
um we also ran a voucher scheme in the
earlier days of the programme
um those that's kind of speak for
themselves but if anyone has any
questions shout towards the end and then
in phase two
uh we divided the region into six
subgeographies or lot areas
one was one by air band uh lot four area
which is essentially
north devon torridge and west evan and
the others
were won by giga clear those contracts
were
cancelled in september 29 and we had to
go through a re-procurement exercise
which occupied
the vast majority of last year leading
to contracts being let
on the 23rd of december last year
uh with urban wessex and true speed um
and
the lot geography that relates to teen
bridge which is lot
f was won by airband
um quick overview of historical coverage
so under phase one as i say we used
fibre to the cabinet this is a
technology which runs
which utilizes open reaches existing
infrastructure runs fibre out
to those familiar green roadside boxes
erects a new roadside cabinet next to
them which is a fiber cabinet
ties the two together and then the um
your
service passes the last part the last
leg of the journey
on the existing copper it's an excellent
technology
in an urban area where if you have 400
properties connected to
a cabinet and you enable it for fiber
essentially 400 properties can
access superfast but uh copper being a
metal
has a resistance um and therefore speed
attenuates over distance
so as you move out into rural areas it
becomes a technology
uh whose flaws become ever further
magnified
essentially if you are within 1.2
kilometers
uh a copper line length from a cabinet
um then you will achieve
super fast or higher so somewhere
between uh
24 30 megs to 80 megs if you
are beyond 1.2 but within 1.8 kilometers
you'll get an improvement you'll get
what we term an uplift so you might go
from two
to seventeen it's usually significant
it's usually worthwhile
but it doesn't count as super fast and
so it doesn't count to
our providers figures and what you're
seeing there the green circles with the
telephone in the middle represent the
1.2 kilometer radius from a cabinet
uh the purple fringes then represent
that 1.2 to 1.8 kilometers where you
might expect to see
an improvement we didn't have enough
money uh
by any means to do 100 of the um
the region so our deployment accounted
for
85 to 90 uh which was in line with with
government national targets
although our targets weren't around
percentage coverage they were around
numbers of properties and i think our
target was uh
was that 270 000 figure which which in
the end we exceeded
moving on to phase two with the early
phase two contracts with
airband delivering into the moors uh
there was coverage
um then into the northern and western
part
of the the district and that's
represented by the
the white dots here those properties
were delivered to using fixed wireless
it's an important point to make that
airband are
known as and promoted as specialists in
in fixed wireless
but i suppose around 18 months ago they
did move into
fiber deployment and their deployment
now is almost exclusively fiber
um and certainly as far as the lot f
contracts are concerned
they won't be delivering using wireless
they will be delivering using fiber
to the premise so this slide
historically shows their wireless
coverage but going forward
it will be fibre just picking up on
giga clear contracts um those were let
at the end
of 2016 and due to run 2017 through to
the end of 2019
um they notified us and to an extent we
were aware
in october 2018 that they were
struggling and they identified a whole
range of issues
one was around their subcontractors and
they contracted the vast majority of
their
the civil engineering work too caring
and talented promptly collapsed
which did obviously introduce uh had a
significant impact on the deployment
but there were other issues there were
issues around um the design methodology
which didn't perhaps mesh
uh as well with uh southwest terrain and
the terrain that they were moving into
as it had in in other areas where they
had
uh successful um deployment history
um they injected to to rectify the
situation
they were um essentially as a company
bought out by a venture capital firm
infra capital
who injected significantly more funds
into the localized contracts
and they massively increased their
capacity within the region
but they had to redesign and come up
with a number of remedial plans
but ultimately um those were not
successful and we terminated the
contracts
in september of that year which led us
to then
need to reprocure you can't just
obviously
hand contracts of those kind of sizes
out to
somebody else you have to go through an
entire process of due diligence as
covered by
uk procurement law and governed by state
aid regulations
so this essentially sets out the um the
work that was undertaken
to get us to a successful re-procurement
i
i won't go into too much detail but feel
free to to ask questions
but it is essentially a year's process
and there is no way of short circuiting
it was critically important that we did
deliver within this time
frame because the state aid clearance
for
any funding on the superfast program
ran out at midnight on the 31st of
december 2020
so if we had overrun by a day uh
everything would have been null and void
and we would not have been able to let
the contracts
and it's another reason for ensuring
that absolute
attention to that due diligence process
and the the regulations around
procurement
were followed to the minutiae of the
letter
um because any failure to do so would
have potentially resulted in a legal
challenge but that would have delayed
the process by three months and we would
have timed out
so having got a band and others into
contract it's important i think to
take you through what happens next um
the first phase is mobilization
and that's taking the detailed
plans from their procurement their
tender returns
and turning them into reality so it's
about getting the remainder of their
staffing in place it's about signing the
contracts that they've been negotiating
with subcontractors on it's about
firming up
the indicative designs which they
produced to enable them to
cost and complete the tender but but
firming them up into a position that
they can actually be
taken out and tested which is the next
phase
so the the survey and design process
probably
should be design survey design so you
firm up the designs
and then you go on to the streets the
roads and the lanes to check your
so your design assumptions and those are
around
are the ducts that you're intending to
use actually there are they
blocked or silted is there work required
are the telegraph poles that you're
intending to string fiber from
are they there are they rotten uh what
do you need to do
if you're intending to go across private
land that will necessity necessitate
whey leaves and so you start that in
process so that's the whole
design and that's the first visibility
that communities get
so within that process it's critically
important that there is
early engagement that explains the
communities what's happening what the
ramifications are
and in many instances where they can
help
then move on to the planning phase so
you've been out and surveyed and
designed you've identified that some of
the dots are blocked
you've identified that some of the
telegraph polls
need replacing so you need to plan in
those remedial works you need to secure
the whaleys that you've identified
negotiate with landowners
um great and small and just have
everything
ready to go you need to submit your road
permits
and you need to schedule your
subcontractors
with a view to it will take this amount
of time to
get all of that done and we then need to
be able to
get people cracking and working um on
the
the roads and the geographies necessary
that's then the build process so
stringing fiber splicing
running fiber out to individuals
properties
and then go live whereby on a
substructure by substructure so within
lot f there might be i think there are
35
sub networks if you like so as each one
is completed
um airband will notify us we will go out
and assure those and check that the work
has been done properly
to standard in parallel they will
test to make sure that it is all working
um there aren't any breaks in the system
and then through community engagement
the community will be notified
that the uh the network is indeed live
and they can place orders
so lot f looks like that it's the purple
shaded area running down through
and encompassing um both yourselves
the tool bay is slightly misleading
because it doesn't particularly impact
that far into tour bay
um and obviously the south hams as well
our level of confidence in airband and
other suppliers
um emanates from not only the
um detailed information they submitted
within their tender but the points that
are called out on this slide so whilst
the the three of them are smaller
suppliers um
suppliers tend to be compared against
open reach as the
historical de facto um monopoly supplier
across the uk
we've all grown up being used to the gpo
the post office bt
etc but the marketplace is increasingly
competitive
and uh in part by design uh and
these these firms have a track record
they have scale
they are they are all i mean airband is
certainly over 10 years old
and a lot of experience and not just
experience generally
but experience within the cds patch so
they know our territories
many of their staff come from within the
region they understand the geographies
and they have built at scale so between
the three of them i think they've
delivered around
45 000 premises they are delivering 56
000 but essentially they've already
built
at a kind of comparable scale uh to that
which we're we're looking
to them to deliver now um they have
regional offices
several of them are either based in the
region um or just outside
they have their investment um secured
rather than needing to bring it in later
um and they delivered successfully in
other parts of the uk
on similar contracts finally that bottom
left box is an important one
pias passive infrastructure access
and this relates to something that's
changed
over i would say the last 18 months or
so and has become much more of a reality
whereby telecoms providers
can use existing passive infrastructure
which essentially means the ducts in the
roads and
the telegraph polls belonging to another
provider
and as i'm sure you can imagine this
massively speeds up
the ability to deploy and in many cases
reduces costs which means that you can
reach more people and that that has been
quite a sea
change within the industry so overall
um i suppose the the school card for the
district
um our records indicate you have uh just
shy of 68 000 premises
within the district under phase one to
date
we've delivered uh cds 21 000
and uh industry has uh contributed 35
000
so we have addressed 56 of those 67
and you can see that's nearly 83 percent
planned
we have within the airband contract um
the airband contract is actually about
4900
and then we have one or two other i'd
want to call them bits and bobs one or
two other
um additional things that contribute to
that 5200
um projected target in industry has
notified us that they're intending to
deliver to another thousand premises
which gives us uh an overall total of 62
000
so at the end of this process you will
be at 92 93
coverage depending um which gives us
another 5 000
to address um i'm gonna skirt over the
slide
but you're very welcome to read it when
when i circulate them
um so how do we address those 5000 there
are
four different ways um we have a fiber
extension program
which uses at present open reach but
more importantly this relies on
money that we gain back from
previous contracts as a result of
in this case open reach increasing their
customer base
over and above a projected target so
essentially they said
we think we will get take up of 20 and
that's what we have modeled our figures
on
the reality is that they're currently on
the work that we did
approximately 70 of those 300 000
properties have taken a super fast
service
so their predictions were were much
lower and the difference between those
generates revenue back into the program
to allow us to then spend on further
broadband
and really it's because if we pay for a
new shiny
infrastructure and that allows providers
like open reach and others
and the clause is present in all the
contracts to increase their customer
base
they will be generating more revenue
they will be having increased profits
and from those increased profits the
money flows back into us as a percentage
so
uh windfall tax if you like or just
essentially a recognition of that
similarly the um at a national level
there is the rural gigabit voucher
scheme and that is designed for
a community that is not part of a
current rollout
to attempt to produce their own plan so
they
approach and work with a telecoms
provider to design a network for
their hamlet their village their parish
and they use the funds from the voucher
scheme
aggregated together to pay for that the
figures are around 1
500 per residential property and 3 500
per business
and we are seeing in more and more cases
those figures are around about the right
level um and they do mean
that in many instances the community can
100 afford
a fiber solution to deliver to their
property
we will work with communities because
actually
with that level of funding it's no
longer the money that's the issue
it's a question of how do you actually
go about doing that how do you
frame your geography how do you choose
which properties to include
how do you find a telecoms provider
who's prepared to do that
and we work with communities all the
time now hand-holding them
introducing them to providers and
supporting them
and that's through our community
challenge program which can also inject
a small amount of funding we have very
very modest funds at the moment but
we're finding that actually the
the scale that we're looking at is is
often four thousand five thousand up to
ten thousand pounds
which represents the shortfall between
the value of the vouchers
and the actual cost of the um the scheme
and so rather than see it fail for the
for the want of
a couple of thousand pounds that's where
we find our money spent which is you
know is excellent leverage
finally overarching all of this is the
national fiber program
uh much of volunteers have been
discussed um at great length over the
last year or so and this is essentially
the idea of fiber enabling the entire
country
when that is to be done by and the
proportion of which
will be covered shifts a bit but it's
another
major investment from government into
fiber enabling rather than simply super
fast enabling
we remain we remain very clear and
focused so we are about
ensuring that people have access to at
least super fast speeds
so we target those people who do not
and particularly those people who are on
sub 10 meg
some sub 5 meg the uh the danger of the
national superfast
the national fiber program is that to
achieve a 100 coverage
you actually have to deliver to a lot of
people who already have
super fast speeds otherwise you don't
have that 100 coverage
um and we recognize that what it's
hugely welcome
that's happening there's a danger of it
starting from towns
and moving out into rural areas
so were it not for a concentration on
superfast
those rural communities currently on
2meg
might actually have ended up being at
the end of the line
for the delivery of the fiber program so
we will go early
on our stated ambition to fight um
super fast enable the region my voice is
going um
council i hope i did slightly better
than last time i think that was less
than 40 minutes
thank you very much do
uh any committee members do you have any
questions or comments
um catch the puck
thank you um just just a quick note from
matt it wasn't yourself i was referring
to
of course it was one of the uh portfolio
holders so
so don't worry about that i do i do
bang on i recognize that so but i'm
pleased it wasn't me on this occasion
it was enthralling trust me um
i was really pleased to hear you say
near the end there that you're going to
concentrate on going to rural areas um
and not go for the low hanging fruit
first of all
and what we've discovered as part of our
covered recovery work
is that those who are in rural areas are
particularly suffering
from not having access to um a decent
reliable
broadband connection and particularly
with schooling and working from home and
all kinds of things so
i mean if there's a if there is that
ongoing assurance that you will be
addressing those rural areas as the
first and most important port of call
um it really helps allay some of the
fears that are out there in the
community
and and if there is a mechanism to
communicate that well to residents
i think that might give them some
reassurance okay
thank you absolutely agreed
thank you catch the morgue um yeah thank
you
um we seem to get these reports every
year and um don't take
this the wrong way but they're often
very slick very colorful
lots of jargon lots of figures but we
need to get down to
the basics and i'm glad you did at the
end and you told us how many have been
connected in team bridge
but there was no time scale on that is
that since the beginning of the project
and we've got another over well five was
it five thousand
to go or we'll have an additional five
thousand can you give us time scales on
this
um because to my mind
having good broadband connection is is
another essential utility like water and
electricity at the moment but you know
particularly
when we're educating children at home
when we're working from home
um and i want to say something about the
bachelor scheme when i hear about
bachelor schemes my heart
sinks because um it just
it just sounds like a gimmick and
actually i think it's something that
you know it either needs to be done or
it doesn't and and
um having voucher schemes where
communities have got to
you know pool their vouchers in order to
get the coverage they need
it's just impractical particularly at
the moment um
so can have some comment on that and
also time scales please
yes absolutely so um so taking your
points
in order the the coverage to date
um the the phase one and early phase two
airband contracts
um i think from memory before my time
but i think the
original contracts were up for 2013 so
bill probably started
2014 2015 so that reflects progress
from uh then uh until now
um the slide that
i glossed over didn't intend to hide or
obscure anything on a
national picture um
it's always a balancing act in in the
extent to which one emphasizes this
because
i'm always quite rightly really
addressing those people who haven't been
connected
but i think it it would be in a mission
to point out that between
um cds and industry we have delivered
fractionally shy of a million premises
over the cds patch within that time um
in parallel with that the the baseline
that we have been delivering to has
grown
from around a million premises to i
think one million one hundred and eighty
thousand
so um all things being equal we
would actually have delivered a hundred
percent superfast one might argue
numerically
um but that doesn't help those
properties who are not connected
and i completely get that so on time
scales the
um the contracts that or the contract
that i outlined with airband delivering
um an additional circuit 5000 premises
into the region
um operates from now until the
end of 2023 so there is a
there is a a three year period for
deployment
um on
on time scales
i understand the frustration i i really
do understand
and particularly because i'm the only
one or one of the few on here who
doesn't have video because i don't have
sufficient broadband
to stream video so i i personally
understand the frustration of not being
able to access
decent speeds and and that is what we're
about
um fiber to the cabinet was
an excellent technology as far as speed
of deployment was concerned because you
had that
point to multi-point you enabled a
cabinet 400 people benefited 500 people
benefit
or whatever fiber to the premise is a
better technology that delivers more
quickly
but does take longer to
actually deliver because you are
essentially going
to every single property that you want
to deliver so a comparator
and an appropriate comparator um would
be looking at the existing copper
infrastructure
so we do now have a a telecoms network
based on copper that essentially serves
100
of the population you can find a couple
of houses that don't but essentially
it's a it's a
it's a universal network that's taken
over 100 years to roll out
and what we're attempting to do now with
fiber we're attempting to do
in a significantly shorter time frame
three to five years
again it's not excuses but you do have
to go
to every property so it is not something
that can be achieved
instantaneously much much though we
would like it to
um to your your point about voucher
schemes
um i genu
i understand the point about uh it
feeling perhaps um as though communities
are being
asked to take responsibility where the
state aid intervention
um has not yet provided a solution i
i understand but i don't agree i think
it is
another approach um and one that
we are genuinely working with a whole
range of communities
across the region um and that's why we
provide support because i recognize
that that simply providing a mechanism
that says you can have these
you can have this amount of money um if
you want to do something yourselves
could be seen as an abdication of
responsibility and it is anything but it
is a
a tactical way of particularly allowing
smaller providers that don't necessarily
have the scale
to bid for large scale contracts like
our recent procurement but absolutely
have the ability to deliver networks at
the kind of scale a community would want
so i'm currently working with um
a provider who's delivering a project
actually very near where i live in
in the most or some of the most rural
parts of somerset
um and they're essentially you know it's
it's him and two other people but
they've connected
200 properties over the last eight
months
pure fiber there's no way that they
would have bid for for any of
our contracts they're not that scale of
company but they are
delivering networks that are making a
you know a genuine
genuine difference to people's lives so
i
think if on the voucher scheme if
communities were just
left to themselves um i i would take
your point but
that's the one of the things that we're
seeking to do
and support to enable uh communities to
access
that kind of money and the reality is
across the
the cds patch i think we have one of the
highest drawdowns of
vouchers across the country um i think
the last time i saw the figures which
are probably three months
out of date we had something like 6 000
properties that have been connected
across the region
which represents a contribution
additional contribution
to the delivery of connectivity in the
cds patch of around eight and a half
million pounds
and those are all people who have full
fiber
um connections uh where they had
previously been languishing on on some
of the lowest speeds possible
i'm conscious that i may not have
addressed all your points but i did have
a stab at it
you happy council organ thank you
um council doors uh thanks very much
uh thanks for the presentation martin uh
i think your image works perfectly and
uh most importantly we can hear you
perfectly which is something that uh
that i don't experience when i attend
four different parish council meetings
and
uh they are rural uh some people simply
cannot get on
and and and we listen to people sounding
like dialects and they have to ring up
on the phone
uh so i sort of echo what sort of
repetition really from from what
counselor parker khan and morgan that
have stated is is that there is a
necessity
uh it's more focused than ever before it
is
indeed uh clear that the broadband
access is now
a human right it's a necessity uh and i
was wondering
other than the obvious that the there's
motivation to do it and we want to do as
quickly
as possible what what's the potential of
making
a huge step change i mean turbo charging
in a way that
that hasn't sort of been you know been
addressed
because we've got the crisis we've we've
it's been demonstrated
what the problem is uh you know we've
stepped up in
in in in other ways can we double the
amount of money quadruple the amount of
money
you know is it a resource issue that the
the it goes back to central government
as
all problems seemingly do or is it
something we can solve
help solve as a council ourselves i i
think there are
undoubtedly things that um both
councils and parish councils can do to
help
um i think i i would i would make a
number of observations
um one i think is
that to deliver the kind of
full national coverage so full cds
coverage that we're talking about
uh for full fiber over a three to five
year period by anyone's definition
is turbo charging it um and
the fact that the demand uh requires
delivery faster than is is
is currently proposed um doesn't
get away from the fact that uh we're
already delivering on incredibly tight
time scales
i think there is a resource issue or a
capacity issue
um but i'm not sure that it's actually
around
the money um the uh
the the challenges that
um are that need to be solved and
and everyone is working to solve these
and there are solutions
around are around the the capacity of
industry to deliver
there just aren't enough fiber engineers
across the country
to meet the demand but they are being
trained up and open reach
in particular doing an excellent job in
training up new engineers there are
constraints
on the um the respective highways
networks across
both counties and the unitaries you you
can only have
um a certain number of people working on
a certain number of roads at a certain
time
and and we see it time and time again i
mean there's a recent example
where um there was delivery into a
village in
in mid devon um and they were asking
why it was that more of the work
couldn't happen
uh simultaneously um so in parallel
rather than in series
and and the answer in that case very
simply that the roads that they were
suggesting
would be worked on simultaneously were
the diversion routes
for the roads that were currently being
worked on and it just wasn't
it's not possible um to work on them all
simultaneously so if you combine
those with just the minutiae of
securing whey leaves which so we're
looking at
one particular build that serves
probably five communities up in the
north daven area and we've got
over 300 whey leaves that need to be
resolved to deliver to
probably 400 properties so it can be
fiendish in its complexity and detail
the the will is absolutely there the
capacity is increasing
uh the fact that we have more alt nets
like air band wessex and and true speed
growing in stature and scale
um i think speaks and is
gives us encouragement and hope that
things will be delivered to time
and any prospect of things going more
quickly
we will we will absolutely do everything
that we can at a
at a district and parish level just
common sense everyday support um
encouraging landowners to to be quick
about signing way leaves um will will
really speed up the process
being understanding about um future
notification of desire to work on on
road works
um being receptive to requests to
not park in a certain street because you
know there's a
there's a need to work on overhead
infrastructure for a
a certain period but actually
that really is the responsibility of um
the provider and in parallel with mcds
ourselves to make sure that the
engagement with communities
is is correct because if they understand
what's happening why it's happening and
the reasons that perhaps a bit of
flexibility is required
99 of the time communities will bend
over backwards to be supportive but if
the engagement
isn't right and they don't understand
why then they
may be less amenable and that
really slows the process down
thank you um councillor dawes does that
answer your question
thank you um so executive members
councillor mcgregor
hello chair the reason my video is off
is because i actually have quite a poor
connection today one of my wi-fi
connections keeps dropping in and out
but um essentially my question is more
around the
developer element so in both
presentations i witnessed today
um one of the comments that's come up is
about developments and
and how we have to work with those
because they're adding houses into the
system
would it would it be fair to say that we
perhaps should look at
asking developers to put the
infrastructure in as part of the
development
whether it's a small development in the
countryside environment or
a larger town development just just as a
matter of interest
thank you chair um yes absolutely so
on uh there has been some
legislative moves in this direction
which i think would also
be really helpful um if at a district
level that was
that was supported uh you know within
the the planning process
i i have to admit to being slightly
um unsure of my ground but i'll tell you
what i know and and why i'm unsure
um essentially there were changes uh
that were proposed for um to make it a
requirement for
new developments initially it was new
developments of
around uh 100 properties or above
needed to have fibre to the premise laid
as a a part of the
conditionality of that development um
that it was then proposed that that
figure
dropped to i want to say 28 premises
um and that any development over that
size would be again
required to have five to the premise um
as
as a condition where i
last lost track of this was that it was
legislation
that became uh snarled up
in the um parliamentary backlog as a
result of
brexit negotiations and uh developments
so i have to be honest i am not sure
whether that
has now been passed into legislation
if not i think there was cross-party
support for it
and certainly support across um at cds
level
and that would that would make a
significant difference because we do
spend
a fair amount of time um
dealing with people who who have
purchased properties in new developments
and then are amazed to find that they're
actually connected
to um a copper cabinet um
and actually often that copper cabinet
doesn't it's not even a copper cavernout
on the development
it's it's one a minute and a half down
the road that had
the capacity to accommodate that
development but actually because they're
they're that far away they don't
actually get super fast so
um sorry i could have just said yes um
but it's
it's a really live issue but one that is
being addressed from a number of
different directions
thank you
no further questions thank you very much
thank you
thank you very much matt that was very
detailed presentation i had several
questions which you've already answered
in great detail
um on your way through so thank you very
much pleasure
um thank you very much so just to to
reiterate um if
if any questions do occur to um
colleagues and counselors on the call
um do you have my contact details or
certainly neil and trish do
just um just email me and i'll look into
them
thank you and you indicated you could
send round those slides
yeah absolutely i'll make sure i'll do
that later okay thank you very much for
your time i will leave you um
enjoy the rest of your meeting thank you
very much
so we'll move on to item nine then the
budget
um so i'll ask
the executive member councillor keeling
to introduce the budget item
um martin flickcroft is also here and
will present the budget in more detail
thank you mr vice yeah thank you mr vice
chair
um i'm i'm very happy to present this
final budget report 2021
22 and beyond dear colleagues
can i first pay tribute to all our staff
who have contributed to the savings made
some two million pounds
my thanks also to our chief financial
officer who's here today
martin flincroft and his team
on the fourth of february we received
the final settlement from government and
there are no material changes between
the provisional settlement
that i shared with you on the 12th of
january and the final settlement
for team bridge district council
colleagues i would like to bring to your
attention
the new homes bonus a new round of
allocations were
announced in the settlement this is year
11.
these allocations are a one-off and will
not be attributed to
future legacy payments in fact the
written statement
underlines that this will be the final
settlement
of allocations under the current
approach
ministers are also keen to replace this
and plan to consult shortly on the
future of this
there are also no guarantees given
about the local government funding
reform we are still
expecting the reform to be implemented
22
to 23 but the government written
statement only commits to revise
the priorities for financial reform in
the time
for the next spending review ministers
will also be taken into account
the wider work on the future of the
business rates
so our final budget proposals are to
date
for the latest lockdown so no
significant changes apart from the
budget gap
widening next year to 1.2 million
so moving forward we expect next year we
will be
balanced by an earmarked reserve
a budget gap of 1.2 million 22.23
and 2.6 million in 23.24
so over the three years we have a budget
gap of 3.8 million pounds
we also have to consider whether we can
reinstate the 0.5 million
that's 0.5 revenue contribution from the
reserve to capital
and we will keep this as an option
i am very pleased that we've all worked
together across
all political groups and we can and will
take team bridge
into a great recovery and a sustainable
place to work
and live martin will now take you
through our
funnel slide and add detail
we will both be happy to answer
questions at the end
martin please
thank you um just to quickly run through
the report first and then we'll go to
the
funnel slide afterwards so these are the
final budget proposals for the years 21
22 and going through to 23
24. the figures in the report
are based on the provisional settlement
from government
but as has been indicated the final
settlement has now been received i've
gone through the numbers there are no
changes for team bridge so
they are what they are um and
in terms of the referendum limits they
stay the same as well being the higher
of
supercenter or above five pounds um
all that goes to parliament tomorrow and
should be approved
parliament tomorrow the figures have
been updated from the initial budget
proposals to reflect
their latest lockdown and there are no
material changes to the
capital programme the final budget
proposals
also include a mid-year review of
treasury management
and that's to be noted by council and
some extra details in the appendices
around costs per service area
the key recommendations include a five
pound increase in cash flow tax to 180
pounds and 17 pence
increasing climate change funding
continuing funding for enhanced planning
enforcement maintaining revenue reserves
at just under 2 million pounds
increasing support for housing with the
team ridge 100
infrastructure delivery plan investment
continuation of the grant funded
southwest regional coastal monitoring
programme
and town center investment in
infrastructure and employment
section 2 of the executive report sets
the scene around reductions in
government funding
savings covered 19 impacts and the
inclusion of the team rh100 in the
capital programme
together with provisions for climate
change projects and the future high
streets funds bid
section 3 of the report provides more
detail on the savings made
to assess where the budget gaps are
rising in particular
section 3.3 and future costs on the
council and 3.9
and the mid-year review of the treasury
management function is in 3.11
section 4 covers the revenue budget at
appendix 4
and fees and charges of appendix 5.
there are general inflationary increases
in most charges
and some charges at newt number market
have been frozen
after having been reduced last year
4.2 to 4.4 gives more details on fees
and charges
section 4 also looks at our proposed
change in council tax
and provides a multi-year summary of how
our funding has changed from government
to include revenue support grant
business rates and new homes bonus
a reduction of 35 percent over that time
period
the key paragraph is 4.27
and how we've funded the budget gaps we
still have
a budget gap of 1.2 million in 2223
and 2.6 million in 23.24
on top of that would be the aspirations
to put at least half a million pounds
back into our capital program as revenue
contributions
and failure to do the savings obtain
greater funding from government
could trigger the issue of section 114
notice in the future
section 5 of the report includes details
of the capital program
there are no material changes from the
initial budget proposals
and that's appendix 7 and they include
various schemes including the
team bridge 100 climate change
infrastructure and employment
section 6 covers consultation on the
budget proposals
and the outcomes from our budget survey
and those will be reported to executive
on thursday
and form part of the full council budget
report by an additional appendix
on the 22nd of february i think
i'll move on then to show you
the funnel chart that we've got
this one is one that we've done every
year which members have found
quite useful and it shows the
income and the expenditure on both our
revenue and capital budget for next year
the income being on the top half of the
sheet and the the expenditure on the
bottom half so
start on the top left um we've got
the income from the revenue budget so
you've got your fees and charges
for a lot of different services for
leisure parking and planning etc
10.5 million you've got property income
other income and contribution from
reserves at 9.8 million
that also includes recycling credits
sales of recycling
and significantly to balance the budget
next year 3.3 million from reserves
the casual tax 8.7 billion
that's our share of the council tax um a
few years ago that used to be 11
of the overall bill dip below eight nine
percent
a couple of years ago and is heading now
more towards eight and a half percent
the specific grants at the top there the
big blob at the top
um that's mainly a housing benefit grant
that comes in some other grants at 26.9
million
then there's the share of business rates
that we retain at 4.7 million
revenue support grant used to be on this
chart as a big blob
not anymore it used to be four and a
half million that's no down to zero
and new homes bonus is dwindling as well
um now at 1.5 million
um due to changes in how that's
been calculated and no legacy payments
going forward
so that gives you an overall income of
62.1 million pounds
which then flows out down the bottom
with
the light green arrows so leisure
open spaces and resorts at 6.1 million
fairly self-explanatory
governance communications corporate
services and transformation
that covers um all of the um
key support services um democratic
services
um hr payroll audit finance
etc it also covers slt
and members allowances that's at 4.8
million
other housing and health services 4.3
million covers
housing environmental health licensing
and customer services
then the big spend at the bottom revenue
and benefits again that's the
um housing benefit monies that we pay
out
so it's a flow straight through and also
the the cost of the housing benefit team
to administer that
you've then got waste recycling and
cleansing at 9.4 million
again fairly self-explanatory
strategic place services including
economy and planning at 9.2 million
that covers building control development
management
planning economy and assets and spatial
planning
and then you've got financing items
which covers pensions
and bank charges and external order and
any contribution to reserves at 2.1
million
so that's the in and out of the revenue
budget then on the right hand side
you've got the capital budget
in the same format so you've got capital
receipts
for asset sales or right to buy money's
at 2.6 million
specific capital grants at 14.5 million
money is from section 106 at 0.8 million
any schemes that require borrowing at
17.9 billion
and still at 2.7 million given us
funding of 38.5
million to match the spend predicted for
next year
in the bottom half of that sheet so
you've got it
at 0.5 million flood alleviation
and environment at 5.5 million that
covers all flood defenses
coastal monitoring carbon management and
climate change
open spaces and leisure at 6.9 million
again covering
play areas sports centers cycle paths
etc
planning and development at 24.5 million
that's employment land and town center
regeneration and the hotel developments
and then the housing grants and
affordable housing at 5.1 million
including the team bridge 100 so
that's just a diagrammatic display of
our budgets for next year
but gives you a different sort of
insight into
the numbers that you've got in the
various appendices so hopefully that's
useful and happy to take questions now
thank you
thank you martin so committee members do
you have any questions or comments
counselor doors all right thanks very
much
the sort of question and i'm sorry you
probably answered this in
other meetings but i just interested in
in terms of income in terms of rental
from commercial
portfolio held by the council because i
remember
uh asking questions on why uh why the
council had invested in commercial
portfolios when
when elected and the the answer was that
it offered a slightly better return than
holding the money uh in a deposit
account
uh i'd imagine those those incomes have
been shots pieces
uh the probably occurring bad debts
and uh equally rates as well uh
will either have been lost or will fall
to bad debts
and uh also i sort of feel the pain of
having to budget as well because the
the costs are in the state of flux as
well given that
certain operations keep changing uh
might cost more
uh but may maybe have benefited from
following i'm thinking of leisure
centers
i just wonder what what element of of
sort of uh well
transparency in terms of what loss of
income uh has been
accounted for accrued for uh and
what sort of flexibility there is in
terms of costs
uh on for ongoing sort of uh
closures that that may happen
yes so thank you for the question yeah
it's an important one because
um the biggest losses that we've had so
far
have been mainly through fees and
charges through car parking and leisure
being closed
but running a very close second are our
rental
incomes and most of those
uh incomes that we get um we've had a
we're having an
ongoing argument with with government
around what's deemed
commercial because they seem to think
that everything that we rent is
commercial
and we've tried to put the case to them
that significant proportion of these
assets that we hold were for economic
development
for revival of town centers
and for employment going forward
so a lot of those while they bring a
commercial return
they they were therefore for many other
purposes other than
straight investment and in fact if you
look at our balance sheet there are only
two
properties that are deemed investment
properties
within those regulations so that's what
we always put back to government to say
you can get support on losses from
fees and charges but you're not giving
us any support on
rental and when these rentals are are
clearly part of a
a bigger delivery um and a lot of that
um
investment has been reinvested as you
can see in newt navitone center
so not something that a commercial
investor would necessarily do
so yes we've had to make a provision for
um rental losses in the same way that
we've done for fees and charges
and i think going forward what will come
out of that will be
a re-alignment or a rebalance probably
generally across the rental market in
terms of
rentability per square foot and so what
we've had to do in terms
of our projections going forward
is a take a look at what might
the bad debt provision be going forward
um
where we might have more void periods
because of businesses closing down
where rentals may have to be realigned
that's
still really difficult you know it's
still part of the crystal ball because
we don't know what's going to happen
with that
and i think across peace as well um i
think
so the government are looking at after
our representations generally
and also i think as part of that um
remit they they do need to look at
business rates as well
to see how how how they work and how how
the model works because
i think it's broken now i don't think it
works in the same way that they
pre-coded and i think the whole thing
needs looking at and i think that's what
come out of the the funding reforms that
come forward
um there will be a lot of consultation
in this financial year
around how that's working or not working
and they'll have to rework i think
how how that's modelled does that sort
of answer your question
it does just for clarity then uh and and
i hadn't really understood uh that you
could do this
in terms of the non-commercial rentals
that you have you put a case the central
government say
can you support that basically is that
the case
yeah so so government ins we've been
doing monthly returns to government
yeah and in that return they've asked
for various income streams various cost
pressures
which we put based on what we've got in
our leisure and what we know and what we
think will happen
um and a separate proportion of that it
was around
um what's happening with your business
rates we've had we've had to guesstimate
where we think they might end up
but they've in there we've said well
actually the way that your form is
designed you're asking for all rents to
go into one box we
a lot of them should go into different
box because they're not commercial rents
in that
respect at the moment they're sticking
to it all in one
box but just recently they've actually
started to ask more questions
so i think they're starting to realize
that it's not commercial rent in the
true
aspect that they they consider so
hopefully
there's some light at the end of the
tunnel now they're going to start
looking at that so
we'll see that's good to know thank you
thank you
thank you very much uh councillor hook
thank you uh andy
i hope very much that we can all
irrespective
view the presentations today
um in in the light of the unique
problems that this authority and every
local authority in the country is facing
problems which no authority has faced
since well
since since the war and
i hope that the fair-minded amongst us
and i hope on this occasion
we can all be fair-minded will applaud
the
fantastic work that the department and
and
um uh the executive have put into
producing this
most difficult of budgets and it really
has been
a trial and i i think we should all
recognize that
um i you know we recognize that i think
with some distance from the edge of the
wood let alone
out of the wood and the problems that
are there for the next year or two
are very real problems but this budget
it's just about as good as it could get
i believe in in the circumstances which
we are facing
so i i applaud unreservedly the um
the the work and the effort and and the
end result this budget
because i see in it amongst other things
that the commitment that i hope we all
feel to
the two very real emergencies that we're
currently faced with
the cv epidemic pandemic which is
causing all the economic problems and
health and social issue problems and all
the rest of it and you know i've i've
received
um on behalf of the council thanks from
different business
businesses in newt um business people
who applaud what the council in
conjunction with the government
are doing to um to alleviate some of
these problems
um and i i think that all those response
will
need our thanks and praise but also of
course and
one issue very very close to my own
heart is the
the commitment that this authority has
to the climate change
uh emergency um and uh
12 months ago we appointed an
outstanding climate change officer
william
who's done an absolutely brilliant job
in in the 12 months
intervening um and and we've gained
dare i say it uh i better be careful
what i'm saying now but but
um we we're gaining have gained a
national reputation with
um our ph being engaged with other local
authorities giving advice
other local authorities contacting us
about how we've managed to do
what we are doing um and
discussions with parliamentarians about
what we are doing
and i think that's that's huge uh praise
due to to
the departments involved um and and to
the officers involved david eaton
uh has worked over and beyond the call
of duty so i
i have no hesitation whatsoever in in
praising
those responsible we are we are gaining
as an authority
um real credibility in in the area of
environmental protection and and climate
change work
i think i'm right in saying and i hope
marty will correct me if i'm wrong but
the budget reflects 3.6 million pound
investment in the climate change work
for the next
three years 1.2 million per year and uh
and 30 000 on top of that
um to see the work through on an annual
basis
can i can i ask i suppose allied
to to all that but maybe slightly
stepping aside from it but but
wishing to register very strongly my my
huge
appreciation of what's being done in
that area um
the borrowing situation from government
um
i think they upped the rates about six
months or so ago from the public work
for the public works loans board
do we have plans um that can go public
yet
do we have plans um to
borrow any more money at the moment for
investment
in entrepreneurial activity i'm very
keen on us
generating um with with credible and um
justifiable investment in
entrepreneurial
work we we just need to produce more
money
as we face the problems of closing that
debt that was outlined
do it do you do you can you confirm the
rate
of the public works loans board and
whether we have any plans to
progress any activity in that specific
area
um i can't quote the figures off hand
but um i mean they are relatively low
and they remain relatively low um and we
think that they will go down further
in the next 12 months um but we're
watching them
them closely and in terms of any
investment
to make a return yes i mean all options
are still on the table and
we'll still look at those to see how how
that maps out and that might perform
part of the
savings proposals investment proposals
as part of the recovery plan so yeah
yeah all options are still on the table
that we're looking at
thank you i would echo gordon's
comments in support of managing to
balance the budget at all
um i did have one comment you're in the
slide that you were sharing
the in the top left you've got a
property another income
uh which is bundled together with
contributions from reserves and that's
9.8 million and i think you said it was
the contribution from reserves was 3
million and something
3.3 million 3.3 thank you um i wonder if
in the diagram those two should perhaps
be teased apart
uh a contribution from reserves does
seem
like a significant recognition that that
we are
living beyond our means or that our
means have been reduced beyond our
requirements
and whereas income from property or
property and other income is is
in effect income um i think it does need
to be recognized
i fully appreciate it's a been an
exceptional year in its exceptional
circumstances but we do need to
uh appreciate and keep uh commenting on
the the red
the constant reductions to our income
streams
anything further from anybody
very well then i would um propose then
uh that uh the committee recommends
uh as laid out in uh the agenda on pages
nine and ten
um i would propose uh the recommendation
as set out
that the committee recommends that the
proposals be considered together with
any subsequent
consultation comments for approval by
the council
um as the final budget for 2122
and the outline plan for subsequent
years um
the the budget includes um as martin has
already listed the contribution to the
climate change officer the ongoing
enhanced planning enforcement
uh the increased provision for the
capital programme for climate change
projects
and it details the other central funding
reductions uh provisional assumptions
for business rates in future years reset
the baseline
and the increased support for housing
including the team cambridge 100
and the other measures as set out and
also
that we recommend to the council to note
the mid-year review of treasury
management at appendix 8 which is pages
63-66
um that would be my proposal uh is there
a secondary are you seconding that
gordon
you're pleased to do that thank you very
much
but i'm pleased to say thank you
um trish could we have a vote on that
then please
um are we doing a roll call or should we
have a show of hands
uh as it's a budget chair i'll do a roll
call if that's okay
thank you okay um check can i just ask
to confirm that we're voting on
recommending that this goes forward to
full council is that
is that yes that's my my proposal is is
that set out in the agenda on pages nine
and ten we are recommending that the
budget
we're recommending the budget to full
council uh
for for acceptance as the as the final
budget yes
and chair if if i may the the um this
recommendation would go forward to the
executive
on thursday yes okay
okay um sorry is everyone happy with
that i do think it's important that we
are always clear what we're voting on
thank you for raising that
council thank you trish
thank you councillor dawes
for wants of upsetting gordon i'm going
to abstain on this not because i don't
appreciate the efforts
uh and and i appreciate the smirks that
are coming off screen but
i think people uh need to accept that uh
cancel the doors uh thank you but could
we perhaps have a vote
there's an opportunity to speak earlier
okay thank you
okay councillor cox in favor
cancer evans in favor councillor hayes
or councillor herc
councillor morgan councillor nuttall
councillor parker khan
majority there's one abstention there's
two four
six eight ten there's ten in favor says
majority is carried
thank you thank you very much um which
brings us to item ten
uh the time is ten to four um we did
indicate that we would have a break
after an hour and a half which would be
in about 10 minutes um but there is only
one more
significant item on the agenda are all
members happy to continue
yes let's continue thank you very much
um so
that brings us to item 10 then the
council's strategy performance
monitoring for q3
um so i'll ask the
executive member councillor connet uh to
um introduce this sorry to present this
report
um uh executive members will then be
invited
to make additional comments on their
areas of responsibility
the committee will be invited to ask
questions at each stage
and i'll also invite executive members
to make comment
so uh catch the connect please uh thank
you very much chairman and uh good
afternoon colleagues uh this ginger the
officer who leads on this work is at the
meeting as well so i'm going to briefly
introduce him
hand over to liz but as you'll see um
the report to you is in stripped-down
format to look at where
the areas where the council is not
achieving its targets
and then a few a few areas where they're
set out
and of course much of it relates to uh
issues beyond our control uh as a result
of the uh
pandemic uh and the impact that's had on
some services for example leisure which
you were talking about
in the previous item as well so i view
the report is very self-explanatory
uh talking about you know the issues
that we face what actions being taken or
what we expect to do
um and i'm gonna ask liz now just to
give a bit more detail on that
and there's no having to take your
questions afterwards thank you chairman
thank you councillor connor and uh good
afternoon so this is the
quarter three performance report
covering october to december
uh last year during which time we had
lockdown number two in place for four
weeks
um the next section is the financed area
it's just a brief overview here but
we've had the detail in the previous uh
item on the agenda
from from martin and councillor
as well so without further ado let's
move to the t10 program
so at the moment we have seven of the
ten programmes on track
uh overall the whole strategy three are
causing concern and these are the same
three that have caused concern
since uh since we've entered into the
kovic
pandemic back in the a year ago
in the quarter in your in your
particular overview scrutiny too
the two are going to town and out and
about active
in terms of performance indicators we've
got 38 reported in this report
uh 11 of these are ahead or well on well
ahead of target
um nine on target and four
underperforming
this is actually an improvement on last
time uh within
the ons2 report however there are no
underperforming pis reported
for the projects we've got 54 projects
in total
included in the report 47 are track
seven are reported with the caution
status
and of those we've got three within the
out and about an active area that are
reporting a caution status
in terms of a little bit more detail
about that we can find that on page 71
of the report
in the appendix area where we've got an
overview of the going to town
area this includes not just the areas of
courtroom but also
some positive areas as well um
which which covers
sorry just just one right place on my uh
my scripts here which covers the uh
the uh schemes to design and deliver
large and small scale schemes in newton
now but they're still continuing
um we've had a principal award of 9.2
million from the future high street fund
and we've got ongoing business support
provided from environmental health and
economic development so it's not all bad
news in that area but
generally across the board it's the
impacts of lockdown and social
distancing measures on the districts of
town centres
which has put this project down as a
caution status
for the out and about an active area
we have uh again it's a caution due to
kovic 19 restrictions
uh leisure centers closed we've got
three pis there which count the number
of people using our facilities and
joining in activities that are currently
on hold
and we've got the three projects which
are also
listed as caution status covering
volunteer task days
very few of those are able to take place
this year
prefer program activities for targeted
groups of people
although this did start uh when we
weren't in lockdown this has
only been impacted now by further
closures and we're not where we'd hoped
to be with that program
and we have developed a plan of
activities and promoted walking
in particular but however the walk this
way walking groups
have also been impacted by the kovo
pandemic
the other areas within the report
are the great places to live and work
investing in prosperity moving up a gear
and vital viable council and they're all
reporting as on track
thank you
thank you um councillor connor did you
have anything to add to that
no that's fine thank you thank you do
any members of the committee
have any questions or comments
thank you i noticed that
uh it is good to see despite all the
circumstances the
numbers of um projects with concerns has
reduced um
i did have a little difficulty marrying
up the numbers in the
initial report with the details that
followed but i understand now that
that's because you've only presented the
details for own s2 is that is that
correct
yeah yeah thank you for that
so thank you um
council do you host do you have anything
so
chair if i if i may say my apologies
it's
um the the executive members for this
committee and nina jeffries who's given
her apologies
right um gary taylor richard keelan and
andrew
mcgregor um their area of responsibility
so that's all covered then isn't it
yeah yeah okay thank you for that i did
look a bit strange
thank you um so uh
the recommendation then is set out in
the agenda on page
67. um a
proposal and secondary is needed do we
have a i'm happy to
propose the recommendation to set out
page 67
uh secondary i think linda pedrick you
secondly thank you very much
um okay we'll put that to the vote then
if you're happy with that chair we could
do a vote yeah
yes let's do that
that's fine are there any against
there's none against any abstentions as
one abstention so it's carried by a
majority thank you chair
thank you very much and i think that is
the last item
on the um on the agenda um
has anyone had i've missed anything
very good trish did you yes chair i was
just going to
um if you don't if i may just going back
to
um the work program and the comment um
of counselor parker khan about the
executive member presentations um she
mentioned that
andrew mcgregor is scheduled for the 9th
of march
um and it was actually fought they're on
a rota basis so we hear
one executive member presentation every
meeting
so they have bi-annual presentations so
it does mean
they're on their second round but that
will mean
that um by the
meeting on the 13th of july we would
have had
all executive members doing two
presentations so that would then take us
back to september
which is when um this committee started
last year
so um that is correct it was just to
point out that that is correct for
councillor mcgregor to be on the next
committee
and councillor taylor is to carry over
from today
thank you okay thank you for clarifying
that
very good then i think that's everything
thank you very much everybody for coming
and i shall
hopefully see you all again soon